ابلت وزاره العدل الامريكيه
وزاره العدل الاسرائيليه
بفتحي تحقيق في واشنطن بشان اغتيال شيرين
ابو عاقله
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيليه عن واشنطن ابلغت
وزاره العدل الاستراليه باحتمالي طلبي
موده وشهادات للتحقيق في وفاته شيرين
انها ستفتح تحقيقا في قتل مراسله الجزيره
لمدير التحقيقات الفيدرالي الامريكي ووزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه يطالبون بتحقيق في
اغتيال الزمان
امريكيه لها الحق في الحمايه الكامله التي
توفر الامريكيين الذي لا يعيشون في الخارج
وفي المقابل قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بين جانس ان قرار وزاره العدل الامريكيه
بالتحقيق في مواصفات بالموت المؤسف لشرين
ابو عقله اعتبر هذا التحقيق خطا الجزيره
تقف وراء جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي ولن
تتعاون مع اي تحقيق خارجي وانا لن تسمح
بالتدخل فيما وصفه بالشؤون الداخليه
لاسرائيل
مهنيا ومستقلا تم عرضه على الامر على
الامريكيين وتمت مشاركتهم بالتفاصيل على
حد قوله
جات هي المتحدث باسمي مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي قال ان شيرين لم تكن مواطنه
امريكيه فحسب بالمراسله شجاعنا لا تحترم
الجميع
وقال ان قلوبنا مع عائله ابو عاقله حسب
تعبيره
الفيدراليه الامريكيه التي تحقيقا
»
بشان اغتيال شيرين هو الخطوه الاولى نحو
المساء التي وفق تعبيرها
الاسرائيليه للتعاون تحقيق
هذا ورحبت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه بقرار
وزاره العدل الامريكيه فتح تحقيق في جريمه
اغتيال شيرين ابو عاقله
ان القرار وان جاء متاخرا فانه يعكس قناعه
الجانب الامريكي بغياب تحقيقات اسرائيليه
جديه واعتبار ما اجرته اسرائيل شكليا في
مطعم للتغطيه على المجرمين
من المحاولات الاسرائيليه المتوسطه لتاسيس
مقتل شيرين ابو عاقله موضحه ان الجانب
الفلسطيني على استعداد دائما للتعاون مع
اي تحقيقات دوليه في هذه الجريمه وغيرها
من جرائم الاحتلال المستمر بحق
الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
شقيق زميله شيرين طوني ابو عاقله على ان
تحقيق الذي فتحته الولايات المتحده بشان
اغتيال شقيقته تحقيق مهم لتحقيق العداله
والمحاسبه الجنات حتى لا تكرر مثل هذه
الجرائم بحق الفلسطينيين
للتحقيق كان متوقعا لان المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين تعودوا الافلالات من العقاب
ومحاسبه المسؤولين لمنع تكرار هذا الشيء
عم بنشوف جرائم في فلسطين من غير محاسبه
ومتمه لانه هذا التحقيق بيكون بدايه
محاسبه اي جريمه كان في حق الفلسطيني
افادت بان فتحه تحقيق امريكيا بشان دوله
حليفه كاس اسرائيل يعتبر امرا غير مسبوقه
في التصرفات الاسرائيليه يعتبر خطوه نادره
قد تزعزع التحالف القويه بين البلدين